claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
première question qui l'objectif
poursuit le président turc arnaud and
mais je crois pour simplifier on pouvait
dire qu'il a quatre objectifs
naturellement le premier est très
général c'est d'établir que la turquie
est devenue un pays incontournable pour
toutes les questions de la de la région
la deuxième le deuxième objectif c'est
la sphère des réfugiés de la poste la
poche d'idlib
la turquie a déjà sur le territoire turc
3 million et demi de réfugiés syriens et
ce qui se passe actuellement à
aigues-vives les bombardements font que
neuf cent mille habitants de la zone se
sont déplacés vers la frontière turque
il pourrait y en avoir deux millions
trois millions et ça pour la turquie
c'est complètement inacceptable
troisième élément la turquie lorsque les
américains se sont retirés a fait
mouvement un mouvement militaire le long
de la frontière syrienne et en syrie et
a repris le contrôle d'une partie du
territoire syrien qui était occupé par
des combattants kurdes qui se battait
d'ailleurs avec les occidentaux et la
russie à modérer un peu cette action
mais a dans le fond installé là la
turquie dans une zone tampon qui se
trouve situé au nord de
la syrie et erdogan veut pouvoir
négocier peut-être même il l'a dit
implanter des réfugiés syriens dans
cette zone là donc il prend il prend
position et puis enfin évidemment il ya
l'aspect politique intérieure pour lui
ça permet de susciter un mouvement
nationaliste en turquie pour peut-être
faire oublier certains déboires en
matière économique et sociale
alors évidemment la la la nature qui n'a
probablement pas les moyens de mener une
véritable guerre contre la syrie
d'abord tout simplement parce que c'est
la russie qui contrôlent l'espace aérien
de la syrie et que par conséquent sa
limite tout à fait les possibilités
d'action et puis on peut penser que en
effet erdogan cherche à dans le fond
c'est comme s'il disait retenez moi ou
je fais un malheur
voilà donc il a il met tout sur la table
en faisant penser qu'il est en état
d'intervenir militairement
ce qui n'est pas absolument certain
alors ça c'est pour les l'objectif
effectivement de la turquie l'objectif
de bachar el assad
bachar el-assad c'est toujours le même
c'est à dire que bien entendu il veut
recouvrait le contrôle de l'intégralité
du territoire de la syrie et
il ya deux parties qui échappent qui lui
échappe actuellement la région d'idlib
où sont stationnés un certain nombre de
combattants qui ont été retirés de zones
d escalade qui sont et qui se trouvait
ailleurs en syrie
et puis la fameuse zone tampon
d'ailleurs et par conséquent et il
voudra tôt ou tard retrouver le contrôle
de ces zones alors évidemment l'argument
c'est de dire dans la zone du 10 où il
était convenu que les turcs désarmerait
les rebelles
ce qui n'a pas aidé les faits et les
rebelles tirent sur les troupes
syriennes à la russie dans ces
conditions à ce qu'elle peut rester
larbitre de la situation larbitre je ne
sais pas mais sans doute un régulateur
et un modérateur
parce que évidemment la syrie est
l'alliée de la russie et la russie va
protéger la syrie mais la russie n'a pas
non plus intérêt à déclencher une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire et a
déclenché un déferlement de plus de deux
millions de réfugiés syriens sur la
turquie se dit très probablement les
réprobations internationales
alors c'est probablement ce qui fait
l'intérêt de la saisine du conseil de
sécurité aujourd'hui
alors justement conseil de sécurité à
l'onu ce soir qui s'est achevée à
l'heure qu'il est qu'est ce qu'on peut
en attendre comme résultat évidemment
c'est d'abord un jeu rôle c'est à dire
que dans le jeu de rôle les américains
soutiennent la turquie mais ils la
soutiennent verbalement les américains
se sont retirés
ils vont pas intervenir militairement
les russes soutiennent leur allié syrien
et puis les français dénonce une
catastrophe humanitaire une urgence
humanitaire
que fait-on que peut-on faire pour les
trois millions de personnes qui sont
dans la région d'idlib dans la poche
d'idlib et effectivement le mérite de la
saisine du conseil de sécurité c'est que
peut-être ça va dépendre des deux
ultimes conclusions le conseil de
sécurité pourrait re discuter de cette
question dans quelques jours de façon à
ce que la tension retombée à modérer les
ardeurs de monsieur erdogan
le péril imminent des escalades que
craint l'onu l'émissaire de l'onu en
syrie
on vous craignez aussi oui il est réel
d'autant plus que dans ces cas là tout
peut déraper à tout moment mais il me
semble que dans son rôle de modérateur
la russie peut probablement calmé le jeu
pour cela il faut en effet arrêter
l'offensive syrienne sur la zone dite
libre
et puis négocier continuer la
négociation qui a été engagée avec les
turcs pour trouver une solution sûre
pour les populations qui sont en zone
est libre mais aussi pour la zone tampon
qui se trouve au nord
merci beaucoup claudin blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nos experts en
relations internationales merci